Piensen en los alimentos
producidos en el mundo cada año.
¿Difícil de imaginar?
Imaginen que son toda la humanidad,
y que en el plato que tienen en frente
está toda su comida del año.
Han hecho todo tipo de trabajo
para llevar la comida a la mesa.
Deben estar ansiosos por consumir
el fruto de su trabajo.
Y las verduras,
las carnes,
y los wafles de su trabajo, también, ¿no?
Bueno, por extraño que parezca,
un tercio de esa comida
termina en la basura.
Un tercio de la comida del mundo,
se estima que unos 1300 millones de toneladas
terminan en la basura.
Todo el trabajo empleado en la
producción del alimento se desperdicia.
Y, para colmo de males, nos cuesta.
Solo EE.UU. gasta un estimado
de USD 165 000 millones al año
gestionando residuos.
Desperdiciamos alimentos,
energía
y dinero.
Quizá lo peor de todo,
desperdiciamos la oportunidad de cambio,
de hacer más eficiente
el sistema de consumo de alimentos.
Si queremos lograr ese cambio,
deberíamos conocer a una aliada
humilde pero diligente y siempre crucial:
la lombriz.
Las lombrices convierten
los residuos orgánicos
y otros productos compostables
en fertilizantes naturales.
Hasta el 75% de lo que
arrojamos a la basura
puede volverse alimento y material
de vermicompostaje.
Pueden crear un lumbricario en casa
para ver el proceso
de compostaje en acción.
En primer lugar, necesitamos lombrices
no las lombrices de tierra típicas.
Necesitamos lombrices rojas,
Eisenia foetida,
la especie responsable de la mayor parte
del vermicompostaje en América del Norte.
Viven cerca de la superficie,
no cavan demasiado profundo,
funcionan muy bien a temperatura ambiente,
y son muy apropiadas para
convertir residuos orgánicos
en abono usable.
Ahora, las lombrices
puede que sean alimañas
pero necesitan un espacio cómodo
para vivir y trabajar:
algunos materiales donde reposar,
papel triturado o cartón,
un poco de humedad,
y, por supuesto, comida.
Sobre todo, restos de comida,
sobras de alimentos
en leve descomposición.
Las lombrices descomponen
los residuos de alimentos
y otra materia orgánica en "castings",
un sinónimo elegante de "caca de lombriz".
Su excremento está absolutamente
lleno de microbios,
que continúan el proceso de descomposición
y hacen que todos los nutrientes,
que antes se perdían,
estén disponibles de nuevo
como fertilizante.
El cronograma del proceso varía
en función de la cantidad de lombrices,
de la temperatura
y de la cantidad de residuos del lumbricario.
Y hay otro calendario a tener en cuenta.
En un lumbricario sano,
la reproducción de lombrices ocurrirá
cuando las lombrices
alcancen la madurez sexual,
indicada por un alargamiento
de los segmentos
en una estructura bulbosa.
Las lombrices de tres meses
pueden producir
de 2 a 3 capullos amarillos
semitranslúcidos por semana.
¿Pensaban que de los capullos solo salen
polillas y mariposas?
Bueno, ¡no todo puede ser majestuoso!
Los bebés salen del cascarón
en unas 11 semanas.
Cuando el lumbricario parece estar
lleno de fideos vermicelli
es momento de compartir
el botín con los amigos
y crear un club de vermicompostaje.
O quedarse con las lombrices
y montar un negocio.
El vermicompostaje no se limita
solo a pequeños lumbricarios,
es un negocio emergente.
Hay grandes instalaciones que convierten
residuos orgánicos a granel,
e incluso estiércol,
en rico "casting" negro,
llamado oro negro.
Su valor como aditivo para
el suelo no tiene parangón,
y puede ayudar a las plantas
a resistir patógenos dañinos.
La falta de tierra disponible
en el medio urbano,
sumado al creciente interés por
la agricultura a pequeña escala
indica que hay un mercado
para el vermicompostaje.
Muchas comunidades usan compostaje
como parte de las estrategias
de cero residuo,
y pueden vender sus sobras bioprocesadas
a granjas locales, ávidas de fertilizantes.
Así, en lugar de gastar dinero,
arrojando residuos al vertedero,
podemos transformar residuos en activos,
reingresándolos al sistema alimentario
para que sea más sostenible,
todo ello con la ayuda
de la humilde lombriz,
el diminuto organismo
que nos puede ayudar
a cambiar la forma de mirar el lugar
de la comida en nuestras vidas
y nuestro lugar en el mundo,
siempre que le demos a este pequeño ser
un lugar en la mesa.
Bueno, no un asiento real en la mesa.
Un lumbricario en el cobertizo está bien.